The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: Last
time, I talked a lot
about the semiclassical
method, where we generalize
on this wonderful
relationship to say, well,
if the potential is not
constant, then we can say,
well, the wavelength
changes with position.
And we can say that the
momentum changes with position.
But we're using
this as the guide.
And so the basis is
really just saying,
OK, we're going to take
this kind of a relationship
seriously.
Because v is not constant.
We have V of x.
And we also know that
the kinetic energy,
which is an operator,
is p squared over 2m.
And the energy
minus the potential
is the kinetic energy.
And so we can use this to get a
classical, mechanical function
that this p of x is going
to be 2m E minus V of x.
So why are we doing all
this when we can just solve
the differential equations?
And the answer is
we want insight.
And we want to build our
insight on what we know.
And so we have this
momentum function,
which gives us a wavelength
function, which tells us
how far apart the waves are.
But we also have
another thing, which
was demonstrated by my
running across the room,
and that the momentum is
related to the velocity, which
is related to the probability
of finding the system
at a particular place.
And so we have, if we commit
the travesty of saying, OK,
we have a classical function--
it's not the momentum--
but it's going to somehow
encode the classical behavior,
we can determine without solving
any differential equation what
the spacing between nodes in
the exact wave function is,
and the amplitude
in that region.
And that's a lot
because then we can
use our knowledge of
classical mechanics to say,
oh, this is what we expect
in quantum mechanics.
And that's very powerful.
And I keep stressing that
you want to draw cartoons.
And this is the way you
get into those cartoons.
OK, now, for the
free particle, we
have these kinds of wave
functions, e to the ikx.
And they're really
great because often, we
want to evaluate things like the
integral of e to the ikx times
e to the minus ikx dx.
Well, that's one.
And so instead of
remembering that we
have to evaluate trigonometric
integrals, sine, sine theta,
cosine, we can do this.
And it really simplifies life.
Now, using that insight,
I'm asking you, OK,
the expectation value for
the momentum could be--
OK, if this is the expectation
value for the momentum, what
is psi of x?
I promised I would
ask you this question.
I don't know if anybody
really thought about it.
But first of all, we're talking
about the free particle.
And this is some
sort of eigenfunction
of the Hamiltonian
for the free particle.
So what can we say about k?
We have two parts to
the wave function.
We have an e to the ikx.
And we have a e
to the minus ikx.
And the k is the same
for both of them.
So with all those
hints, what is this?
We have e to the
ikx times something.
And we have plus e
to the minus ikx.
So what are the
somethings that go here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: A and B?
ROBERT FIELD: Right.
And that didn't involve
very much mental gymnastics
if you really have done a
little bit of practicing
of integrals involving
these sorts of things.
Now there's two things.
One is when you have the
same k in e to the ikx
and e to the minus ikx.
The product is one.
If you have different
k's and you're
integrating over all space,
or over some cleverly chosen
region, that integral is zero.
Because these are
eigenfunctions of--
these are different
eigenfunctions
of an operator belonging
to different eigenvalues.
And you always can count
on those things being zero.
Now, quantum mechanics
is full of integrals.
Basically, there's an
infinite number of them.
And most of them are zero.
And you want to be able
to look at an integral
and say, oh, I don't
need to evaluate that.
And often, you want to look
at an integral and say,
I do know how to evaluate that.
And I know an infinite
number of those like that.
And all of a sudden, it starts
to be transparent again.
Because the barrier
between insight and quantum
mechanics is usually a
whole bunch of integrals.
And they're all yours.
And so we like problems
where the wave functions
have simple forms.
And this is true
for free particle.
It's true for the
particle in a box.
We're going to
start talking about
their harmonic oscillator.
And it seems like those
integrals are not simple,
but they are.
I have to teach you
why they're not simple.
So today, we're starting on the
classical mechanical treatment
of the harmonic oscillator.
Then we'll do the traditional
quantum mechanical treatment.
And then, we'll come back
and use these creation
and annililation
operators, which
are the magic decoders
for essentially evaluating
all the integrals trivially.
And then, with all
that in hand, we're
going to make our first step
into time-dependent quantum
mechanics.
And we're going to use
time-dependent quantum
mechanics.
Well, we're going to use
our facility with integrals
to describe the properties of
some particle-like state we
can construct.
And these constructions
are really simple
for the particle in a box
or the harmonic oscillator,
depending on which
properties you want.
So your ability to draw cartoons
and to use classical insights
for the particle in a box
and the harmonic oscillator
will be incredibly valuable
once we take our first step
into the reality of
time-dependent quantum
mechanics.
Now, one of the things
that's going to happen
is that we're going to
describe real situations,
real situations that are not
one of the standard solved
problems.
The standard solved problems
are the particle in a box,
or a particle in the infinite
box, the harmonic oscillator,
the hydrogen atom,
and the rigid rotor.
And the particle in a box--
so the potential for each
of these is different.
It looks like this.
And it looks like that.
So there is no stretching
in a rigid rotor.
And so all of the complexity
is in the kinetic energy, not
the potential.
But each of these has a
different potential energy.
And the energy levels
for the particle in a box
are proportional to n squared.
For the harmonic
oscillator, they're
proportional to n plus 1/2.
For the hydrogen atom,
they are proportional to 1
over n squared.
And for the rigid rotor, they're
proportional to n times n
plus 1.
So one of the
valuable things you
get from looking at these
exactly soluble problems
is that the energy level
patterns for each of them
are slightly different.
And you can tell what you've got
from the energy level pattern.
And so when you take a spectrum,
so often you want to know
what kind of spectrum is this?
Sometimes you can tell just by
what frequency region it is.
But usually, in a
spectrum, there's
a pattern of energy levels.
And that gets you focused on
well, what kind of problem--
what is the nature
of the building
blocks that we're going to use?
So this is wonderful.
Now, we're also going
to find that when
we solve these problems
in quantum mechanics,
we get an infinite number of
eigenfunctions and eigenvalues.
And often, we get presented
to us a lot of integrals
involving the operators between
different wave functions.
And one of the
beautiful things is
when the theory gives
you an infinite number
of those integrals.
So now we would
have a collection
of all sorts of
integrals that are
evaluated for us in a simple
dependence on quantum numbers.
So what do we do with them?
Well, there's two main things we
do with these infinite numbers
of integrals.
One is we say, well,
this problem is not
the standard problem.
There are defects.
Instead of having the potential
for the harmonic oscillator
that looked like this,
it might look like that.
There might be
some anharmonicity.
Or there can be all
sorts of defects.
And these defects can be
expressed by integrals
of some other operator.
And that goes into
perturbation theory.
Or if we're going to want
to look at wavepackets,
creating a particle-like
state and asking
how it propagates in time,
those integrals are useful.
So there's all sorts
of fantastic stuff,
once we kill the
standard problems.
It's not just some
thing you have to study,
and it's over with.
You're going to use this.
As long as you're involved
in physical chemistry,
you're going to be using
perturbation theory
to understand what's going
on beyond the simple stuff.
OK, so let's get started.
So why is the harmonic
oscillator so special?
If we look at any potential
energy curve, any one
dimensional problem,
it's typically
harmonic at the bottom,
no matter what it does.
I mean, this is a typical
molecular diatomic molecule
potential.
We have a hard inner wall.
And we have bond breaking
at the outer wall.
And so this is an
anharmonic potential.
But the bottom part is harmonic.
And so we can use
everything we learn
about the harmonic
oscillator to begin
to draw a picture of
arbitrary potentials.
So this is hard
wall bond breaking.
Now, we're mostly chemists.
And breaking a bond is--
how much energy does it
take to break a bond?
Well, is that encoded
in the spectrum?
Yeah.
So this is the sort of
thing we would care about.
And now let me put
some notation here.
So this is the potential.
And this is the potential of--
the internuclear resistance,
which is traditionally called R.
We're going to switch notations
really quickly from R to x.
But this, the minimum of the
potential, is the equilibrium
internuclear distance R sub e.
So for R near R sub e
the potential V of R
looks simply like k over 2, a
forced constant, R minus R sub
e squared.
So this is harmonic oscillator.
And now we're going to
change notation a little bit.
We're going to use lowercase
x to be R minus Re.
In other words, it's
the distortion away
from equilibrium.
And we can take any potential
and write it as a power series.
Sorry.
And so on.
So if we know these derivatives,
we know what to do with them.
OK.
So one standard potential is
called the Morse potential.
Because it looks like this.
It looks like what you need
for a diatomic molecule.
And the Morse potential
has an analytic form,
where the potential v
of x is equal to D sub
e, the dissociation energy,
1 minus e to the minus ax.
Well, that doesn't look
like polynomial of x.
But we power series expand
this, and we get a polynomial x.
OK, now, what is this D sub e?
So if x is equal to 0--
this is 1 0.
And so we get the energy.
The potential at
x equals 0 is 0.
And if x is equal
to infinity, v of x
equals D sub e,
so basically, this
is the energy between
the bottom of the well
and where it breaks.
This is D sub e.
OK?
So this is well interpreted.
All the rest of the
action is in here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Do you
just square the x?
ROBERT FIELD: Yep!
Thank you.
It's an innocent factor.
But it turns out to
be very important.
OK, so let's square this.
We have v of x is
equal to De times 1
minus 2e to the minus ax
plus e to the minus 2ax.
OK, so we're going to do power
series expansions of these.
And you can do that.
And so we have
plus some function
of x plus some function
of x squared, et cetera.
Now, what is the function of x?
We're taking our derivatives at
the equilibrium, at x equals 0.
And we have a potential,
which has a minimum.
So what's the derivative of
the potential at equilibrium?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
ROBERT FIELD: Right.
And so the x term goes away.
And so we have a constant
term, which we usually
choose to be zero.
And we have this quadratic term.
Looks like a
harmonic oscillator.
And then there are
other terms which
express the personality
of the potential.
This is universal.
And the rest becomes
a special case.
So we have v of
x is De a squared
x squared plus other stuff.
OK, we're going
to call this 1/2k.
why?
Because we'd like it to look
like a harmonic oscillator.
I mean, we know
that the potential
for a harmonic oscillator
is described in this way.
So let's just draw a picture.
So we have a spring and a mass.
And I should have drawn
this up a little higher.
OK, so at equilibrium
there is no force.
If the mass is down here,
there is a force pulling it up.
And if it's up here, there's
a force pushing it down.
Hooke's Law says
that the force is
equal to minus k x minus x 0.
OK, and now we're going to
switch to just the lowercase x
in a second.
But now, the force
according to Newton
is minus gradient
of the potential.
So the potential
for this problem
is v of little x is
equal to 1/2k x squared.
OK, so we have what we expect
for a harmonic oscillator.
And we're going to say the small
displacement part of the Morse
oscillator looks like 1/2k.
x squared looks harmonic.
And so what do we do now?
Well, one of
Newton's laws, force
is equal to the mass
times the acceleration.
And so we can say, oh,
well, the acceleration
is the second derivative
of x with respect to t.
And the force is a minus
gradient of the potential.
So it's minus 1/2kx squared.
Minus kx.
OK, so this is the
gradient of the potential.
This is the mass--
well, I need the mass--
times the acceleration.
And so this is the
equation we have to solve.
And so we want to find
the solution x of t.
And this is a second order
differential equation
because we have a
second derivative.
So there's going
to be two terms.
And they'll be-- we'll have some
sine and some cosine function.
And we're going to
want a derivative,
a second derivative, that
brings down a constant k.
And so we know that
these are going
to be things that have the form
a sine kx k or m square root
x plus b cosine k m x.
So this is the solution.
And we have to find A and B.
Now, why do we have k over m?
Well, you can look at this
differential equation.
And you can see that
we have an m here.
We have a k here.
And that's what you need
in order to solve it.
So now our job is
simply to find A and B.
AUDIENCE: Should these be
functions of t and not x?
ROBERT FIELD: You
know, sometimes
I go onto automatic pilot
because it's so familiar to me.
I'm just writing what comes
up in my subconscious.
But yes, that's a good point.
All right, so we want x of t.
And it is this combination.
OK, so now we put
in some insights.
We want to know what the
period of oscillation is.
And so x t plus tau has
to be equal to x of t.
And so when we do
that, we discover--
and I'm just going to
skip a lot of steps--
that k over m square root times
tau has to be equal to 2 pi
in order to satisfy that.
We call k over m
square root omega, just
to simplify the equations.
But we also discover
that this actually
is an angular frequency.
So if we say omega
tau is equal to 2 pi,
then tau equals 2 pi
over omega, which is
equal to 1 over the frequency.
Just exactly what we expect.
So we have the beginning of
a solution and omega, tau,
and frequency make sense.
Everything is what
we sort of expect.
OK, so now the next
step is to determine
the values of the constants.
So normally, when we have
a differential equation,
after we find the general form,
we apply boundary conditions.
And so we're going to apply
some boundary conditions.
So here we have the potential.
And-- so this is the potential
as a function of coordinate.
And this is the
turning point, this
is the inner turning
point at energy E.
This is the outer turning point.
Well, what's true at
the turning point?
The turning point,
the potential is
equal to the energy at
the two turning points.
So 1/2k x plus or
minus of E squared.
So if we know E, we know
where the turning points are.
And so x of plus minus
of E, we can solve this.
And so we have 2E over k.
Yeah.
So this is the turning points.
These are the turning points.
Now, this is a fairly frequent
exercise in quantum mechanics.
You're going to want to know
where are the turning points.
Because this is how you impose
boundary conditions easily.
And so knowing that a
turning point corresponds
to where the potential is
equal to the total energy
is enough to be able
to solve for this.
OK, so suppose we start
at x equals x plus.
And so x of 0 is
equal to x plus.
And that determines one
of the coefficients.
So x of 0--
so we have at t equals
0 the sine term is 0
and the cosine term is 1.
And so the first
thing we get at t
equals 0 is that B
is equal to x plus.
Right?
The next step is to find a.
There are several
ways to do this.
But it's useful to
draw a little picture.
So x plus is here.
And that occurs at t equals 0.
And x minus occurs
at tau over 2.
And in the middle
we have tau over 4.
So let's ask for, what is the
value of the wave function
when x is equal to 0?
So how do we make the
x be 0 at tau over 4?
And that determines the value
of B. I mean, the value of A.
So we have everything we need.
And now, before just
rushing on, let me just say,
well, this just gives
A is equal to zero.
OK, there's a
different approach.
When we have a sine
plus a cosine term,
we can always
re-express it as x of t
is equal to some other constant
times sine omega t plus phi.
And so the same sort
of analysis gives
c is equal to E
over k square root.
And phi is equal
to minus pi over 2.
OK, I'm just writing this.
You want to do that.
OK, so now we're
going to be preparing
to do quantum mechanics, the
quantum mechanical solution
of the harmonic oscillator.
And so there are going to
be other things that we care
about, and one is
the kinetic energy
and one is the potential energy.
And in particular, we'd like to
know the kinetic energy, which
we call t.
And we'd like to know the
expectation value of t
as a function of time,
or just T bar of t.
And similarly, we'd like
to know the expectation
value of the potential
energy as a function of time.
And that's going
to be V bar of t.
And so from classical
mechanics, we
should be able to determine
what these average values
of the kinetic and
potential energy.
So what do we know?
We know that the frequency
is omega over 2 pi.
We know the period
is 1 over omega.
OK, and so T of t is
1/2 mv squared of t,
or p squared over 2m.
But all right, v
is the derivative
of x with respect to t.
And we have the
solutions over here.
And so we know that we can
write x of t and v of t
just by taking derivatives.
And so we have x
of t is 2e over k
square root sine
omega t plus phi.
And v of t is omega times 2e
over k square root cosine omega
t plus phi.
So we want v squared
to be able to calculate
the kinetic energy.
And so we do that.
And so the kinetic
energy T of t is
1/2m m omega squared 2e
over k cosine squared
omega t plus phi.
This here, omega is k over m,
the square root of k over m.
S this is m times k over m.
So we just get k out there.
And so now we would like
to know the average value
of the kinetic energy.
OK, so we have m omega squared.
And so that's k over k.
And so we just get
E integral from 0
to tau bt of cosine square
omega t plus phi over tau.
We want the time average.
And so we calculate this
integral and we divide by tau.
That's how we take an average.
And what we discover is
that this integral is
the numerator is 1/2 tau
times E. No, I'm sorry.
1/2 tau, we have E times
1/2 tau divided by tau.
And this becomes E over
2, an important result.
And we're going to discover
that the average value
of the momentum for
a harmonic oscillator
is E over 2 in
quantum mechanics.
We do the same thing
for the potential.
And we discover that
it is also E over 2.
So we know that E is equal
to T of t plus V of t.
But it's also true that
the average is equal--
so T bar is equal to V bar
which is equal to E over 2.
So now we have an
important interpretation
of the harmonic oscillator.
The harmonic
oscillator is moving
from turning point to the middle
to the other turning point.
And what's happening is
energy is being exchanged
between all potential
energy at a turning point
to all kinetic
energy in the middle.
So energy is going
back and forth
between kinetic energy
and potential energy.
We can solve for the
relationship between T of t
and V of t.
And we can find that V of t
is equal to T minus pi over 4.
tau over 4.
So this is telling us
just what I said before,
that energy is being exchanged
between potential and kinetic
energy.
And that the potential energy
is lagging by tau over 4
behind the momentum.
This is all very fast.
But it's all classical
mechanics, which you know.
And we're going to
be rediscovering all
of this in quantum mechanics.
And so we have to
know what are we
aiming for in quantum mechanics?
So that we can
completely say, yes, it's
consistent with
classical mechanics.
And there's some really--
now, there's another
really neat thing.
So if we look at X of t,
X of t is oscillating.
And suppose we start
out at a turning
point, the outer turning point.
So we can tell from this, the
derivative of x with respect
to t at x equals x
plus is going to be 0.
So at a turning
point, the particle
is hardly moving, not moving.
And so what about the momentum?
Well, the momentum is
going to look like this.
Yeah, it's going
to look like that.
And so at the time that we are
starting at a turning point,
the time derivative
of the momentum
is at its maximum value.
So this is going to be
really important when
we start looking at properties
of time-evolving wave
functions.
Because what we're
going to discover is,
suppose we start our system
here, at a turning point.
And that's actually something
that we can do very easily
in an experiment.
Because when we excite from one
electronic state to another,
you automatically
create a wave packet,
which is localized at a
particular internuclear
distance.
And so you go typically,
to a turning point.
So then, well, what's
going to happen?
Well, there is a thing in
quantum mechanics, which
you will become familiar with,
called the autocorrelation
function.
No, it's not.
It's called the
survival probability.
And that's going
to be the product
of the time-dependent
wave function at x and T,
the time-dependent wave
function at x and 0.
So this is expressing
somehow how
the wave function
that is created at t
equals 0 gets away from itself.
It's a very important idea.
Because you make something.
And it evolves.
And for a harmonic oscillator,
if you make it at a turning
point, this thing changes.
Because the momentum changes.
And the contribution
of the coordinate
to the decay of the
survival probability is--
it's all due to the momentum,
and not the coordinate change.
That's actually, a
very important insight.
Because the momentum, the time
rate of change of the momentum,
is minus the gradient
of the potential.
So this is one way we
learn about the potential
simply by starting
at a turning point
and knowing that this
thing, which we can measure,
is measuring the
thing we want to know.
Now, we will get
to this very soon.
Because I haven't even told you
about time-dependent quantum
mechanics.
But those are the things
that we expect to encounter.
OK, now I want to give you--
I'm going to throw at you--
some useful stuff, which
turns out to be really easy.
Suppose we want to
know the expectation
values, or the average
values, of x, x squared,
p, and p squared.
OK, so we have a
harmonic oscillator.
And do we know what this is?
Do we know the expectation
value of the coordinate?
AUDIENCE: 0.
ROBERT FIELD: We have 0.
Why is it 0?
There's two ways of
answering that question.
But these are easy
questions, which on an exam,
you don't want to
evaluate an integral.
You want to know why is it 0.
And there's two answers.
You said 0, right?
Why did you say 0?
AUDIENCE: Because
it's symmetric.
ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
OK, so there is a
symmetry argument.
Another is well, is
the potential moving?
The particle is in a potential.
It's going back and forth.
The potential is stationary.
So there's no way
that x could move.
X could be time dependent.
So we know this is 0.
What about p?
Same thing, whether you
use symmetry or just
physical insight.
But what about x squared?
Well, x squared is equal
to V of x over k over 2.
So expectation
value of x squared
is equal to the expectation
value of V over k over 2.
But we know the expectation
value of V. It's E over 2.
So we know without
doing any integrals what
the expectation value of x
squared is, and similarly,
for p squared.
And that's just going to
be m times E. OK, so why
do I care about these things?
Well, we have a little
thing called the uncertainty
principle.
And we'd like to know the
uncertainty in the coordinate
and the momentum.
And this is our
classical view of it.
But it's going to
remind us of what
we find quantum mechanically.
So the uncertainty
in x can be defined
as the average value of x
squared minus the average value
of x squared square root.
That's just the variance.
And well, this is 0.
And we know what this is.
So we know that the uncertainty
in x is E over k square root.
And the uncertainty
in p is going
to be p squared average
value minus p squared.
This is still 0.
And this one is then
m times E square root.
So delta x delta p, it looks
like the uncertainty principle.
This is classic mechanics,
is just E over omega.
But what's E over omega?
AUDIENCE: h?
h bar.
ROBERT FIELD: Right.
So it's all going
to come around.
This is related to the
uncertainty principle
in quantum mechanics.
There is a minimum joint
uncertainty between x and p.
And it's just related
to this constant.
Now, this doesn't say
the uncertainty grows
as you go to higher
and higher energy,
as it will in quantum mechanics.
But this is really
a neat thing to see.
OK, I've got two minutes left.
So if we wanted to know
the probability of finding
x as a function of the
coordinate, the turning points.
So here are the turning points.
And we can calculate
what is going
to be the probability of finding
the particle at one turning
point.
Well, it comes
down from infinity,
goes back up to infinity.
So here at the turning points,
the particle is stopped.
And so the probability of
finding it at a turning point
is infinite, times dx.
So we don't have
an infinite number.
In quantum mechanics,
we're going
to discover that quantum
mechanics is smarter than that.
And what quantum
mechanics does, suppose
we have this is the energy.
What quantum mechanics does
is that the probability
at a turning point is not 0.
And there's something--
what happens
is there's tunneling tails that
instead of going to infinity,
it has a finite value.
And it reaches out into
the forbidden region
in an exponentially
decreasing way.
And that's basically
the difference
between classical mechanics
and quantum mechanics.
And there's an awful
lot of important stuff
that happens there.
Now, I've been very
fast through all of this
because it's built on stuff
that you're supposed to know.
And it's built on
stuff that we're
going to work hard to understand
from a quantum mechanical point
of view.
But this sets the
stage for, what
are the things we have to
look for in quantum mechanics?
So I do recommend that
you look at the notes
and make sure you can follow
all the steps, which I went
through incredibly rapidly.
And it'll be really helpful.
Because your job will
be to draw cartoons.
And these will guide
you through it.
OK, so I'll see you on Friday.